le 16 janvier dernier le gouvernement a
pris la décision d'imposer à la france
toute entière un couvre-feu quotidien à
18h mesures strictes est très
contraignante pour laquelle aucune date
de fin n'a été annoncée un long tunnel
sans fin qui commence à s'impatienter
les français l'aja reprend de fer que
travailler que ça devient vraiment
fatigant d'être restreindre nos libertés
sur les réseaux sociaux depuis hier le
hashtag stop couvre-feu est en tête des
sujets les plus commentés
plus de dix mille messages ont été
postés en seulement 24 heures ont
demandé l'arrêt de ces privations de
liberté que certains ne supportent plus
car au-delà d'un possibilité d'aller
voir ses amis sa famille et de conserver
un équilibre social essentiel à notre
santé mentale
beaucoup se demandent si ce couvre feu
sans date de fin et constitutionnel pour
beaucoup le temps est venu de rvi comme
avant
le beau temps revient la deuxième vague
est contenu ça fait des mois que ça dure
et qu'on en a marre n'est pas que des
internautes anonymes qui s'agace le
député france insoumise françois ruffin
a également posté un message contre
cette mesure qui l'obligent à la
débrouille à coincer à paris pour cause
a semblé plus aucune boutique ouverte
avec le couvre-feu obligés de raser avec
le liquide vaisselle
alors stop couvre-feu entêté faut-il
arrêter le cours peut stop qu'on peut
faut-il arrêter le coach tom cruise les
anglo saxons qui nous regarde on à
fabrice di vizio avocat pied pour nom il
a arrêté tout ça demain fabricio en fait
la vraie question c'est est-ce qu'il
fallait instaurer d'accord merci
comment vas y mollo martin blachier
epidémiologiste et la merci martin merci
d'être là ça va fabrice tabriz où son
calme aujourd'hui et 6 passes c'est le
week-end alors je vais déjà vous dit
tout et vous dites non bien évidemment
dit oui oui bah dis donc je vais prendre
quelqu'un qui a des projets le défoncer
castaldi non mais je vais effectivement
oui parce que 18 heures d'effort
nettement à paris personne n'en respecte
malheureusement alors la hongrie des
conneries écoutez ben moi je fais un peu
de rangement
voyez votre chambre je parle mais
honnêtement ballet des boutiques à paris
à 18 heures excusez moi il ya des
bouchons partout les gens sont dehors
donc ça ne sert strictement à rien il
valait mieux laisser à 20 heures il fait
respecter à 20h ou 21h à 18h honnêtement
il ne sert strictement à rien voilà par
une fois vous êtes la corée castaldi
presque oui presse bien mais cette brave
ça c'est du pif on dit 18-20 on dit 21 à
19h30 19h42 ça tout ça c'est du pif en
espagne là ils sont passés de 22 ils
sont en train de passer à 23
l'italie a passé à 22 nous on est passé
de 20 à 18
pourquoi pourquoi pas 19 pourquoi pas 10
sept c'est tout ça en fait tout ça a
aucun sens d'ailleurs l'étude du chu de
toulouse montrait que 18 heures ça avait
potentiellement aggraver l'épidémie
donc bon à un moment ou à bien tout ça
c'est du pifomètre quoi alors marc
cherry moi je dis qu'aujourd'hui la
situation allait sous contrôle à la
limite d'être sous contrôle donc on peut
pas relâché et a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup d'analystes de comme pour
montrer qu'à 18 heures c'était quand
même efficace pour contrôler ce fameux
effet apéro après c'est assez simple
c'est à dire que là où on attrape le
move it c'est qu'on se retrouve entre
amis mairie avait effectivement des gens
qui se retrouver entre amis de 18 à 20
heures ce qui faisait des contaminations
mais c'était lors de ce match on est
passé de 20 heures à 18 heures vous avez
dit que ça servait à rien j'ai passé
trois heures à 18 heures que ça aurait
aucun effet et aujourd'hui on me dit
qu'il faut maintenir un truc dont vous
disiez il ya deux semaines et alors je
vais vous lire regardez vous allez
entendre la boîte thomas ngijol et la
voix de briller c'est vraiment là on est
autant type aux salles deux ambiances
non mais je reste ou répondeur fabrice
je réponds c'est vrai que je pensais pas
que ça allait avoir un effet pour être
honnête mais ça en a eu un
et donc je trouve ça rame le bien est
jamais remis ça permise sur les
tendances sur lesquelles on est
aujourd'hui vous même catherine il vous
dit qu'on sait pas pourquoi c'est
descendu laurie noyer bien que
s'agissant par contre bien qu'en espagne
c'est descendu qu'en italie ça descend
c'est aussi un moment peut-être qu'on
peut se dire qu'on vieillit avec une
épidémie quoi c'est que de temps en
temps
passeur de béni oui peut-être
il faut se dire aussi que ç'a eu une
incidence mais que voulez vous partez du
postulat que peu de noms de zone on a
pas eu d'incident je termine juste va
aussi se dire qu'il ya certaines études
qu'ils ont montré notamment je suis
tombé sur un tapis de nouvelles apps qui
faisait un peu tous les cas on peut
aussi se dire que traduire les études en
dix ans effectivement tu as eu
l'incidence est donc principe de
précaution en cause lorsqu'elle lui dans
collective non non non non le principe
des costumes c'est pas ça on arrête de
mettre une pression c'est pas ça le
principe précaution je prends le presto
négocions sait quand et où ce n'est pas
non mais on prend le principe des
cochons lorsque j'ai un degré de
certitude de probabilité suffisante et
pas me le dire différemment attendait ça
pourtant ce que vous dites oui est ce
que vous avez dit quelque chose
d'intéressant mais finalement on va mais
finalement regarder peut-être que ça
marche
ouais mais c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche justement en matière que je vous
ai dit ici et la police est la règle la
police et la liberté est la règle la
police est l'exception
lorsque je prends une mesure je dois
toujours faire gaffe à prendre la mesure
lamoura coercitives possible et je le
dis ni fait de longs pardonnez moi mais
là vous dites la mesure la moins
coercitives possible à mesure la moins
coercitives possible c'est trop drôle
sinon on passe mais on fait mon nom et
moi j'imagine que dans la mesure où la
mesure là moi non la mesure la moins
coercitives possible c'est pas de
couvre-feu
ensuite s'il faut un couvre-feu il peut
se demander si comme l'a fait l'espagne
22h ou 23h
ça a une incidence sur l'épidémie et
l'espagne par l'espagne non non ils sont
pas prendre mon fils n'est ce pas de la
santé mais si d'ici là
ici un conteneur mission qu'a ouvert
jusqu'à 23h là il arrive de faire
l'inversé ses vrilles passe
effectivement là dans quelques jours
deux ans à 23 heures voilà les zones qui
sont vers le sud à 23h en vertu d'un
droit je connais très bien l'espagne
j'ai vécu trois ans là bas mais trois
divisions depuis le début nous dit oui
il faut arrêter le couvre feu donc est
ce qu'ils vont faire alors il faut qu
lâché il faut relâcher la pression c'est
tout je dire c'est à dire qu'en fait un
moment donné il faut juste qu'on se pose
la question quand l on l'arrête
alors c'est intéressant monsieur
blachier ont l'art est quand on arrête
quand les gens fragiles sont vaccinés
non mais vous rigolez ou quoi
non mais c'est une blague l'attendait le
gouvernement veut donner c'est une
foutaise ce truc le gouvernement vous
dit au départ ouais quand on sera à 5000
quinze jours on pourra imaginer
deux d'entre eux font ils avouent me
balancer quand ils seront vaccinés alors
qu'on n'a pas de vaccin alors qu'on
manque de doses de vaccins dont
attendait dont vous me dit
qu'effectivement on est infoutue de
vacciner les gens et que donc on est
infoutue thaksin et jaune et on va
attendre d'avoir fini de les vacciner
avant de réouvrir pour tout le monde
mais c'est une blague par dix mois c'est
une blague
il est il est colère mais ça c'est de la
foutaise marsac le conseil scientifique
a proposé cette auto confinement des
personnages et c'est dans le sens où je
n'en peux plus je note quand ce truc là
avait été proposé il ya quelques mois
suggérer effectivement tout le monde
criait au scandale je suis encore en
avait je suis d'accord allait proposer
aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on est un foutu de garder une
mesure plus de deux mois et que là on
est en train d'effectivement tuer toute
une génération pour rien juste martin
blachier est-ce qu'on a un foutu non on
essaie de contrôler l'épidémie juste qu
est-ce qu on est vacciné le plus de
monde possible là où je suis d'accord
avec fabrice di vizio ce que je pense
que la jeunesse se laissera par confiner
donc de toutes façons c'est vous je
pense que ça n'arrivera pas donc après
j'espère que l'épidémie va se stabiliser
qu'en être capable de relativement
maintenir ce plateau jusqu'à ce que les
gens soient vaccinés nicolas et monsieur
des visio vous êtes toujours contre tout
j'ai une tour quand même à vous occuper
des contentieux santé c'est votre
spécialité mais oui j'aimerais essayer
de comprendre
c'est aujourd'hui vous avez un service
réac et quasiment saturé ok vous avez
3300 personnes en réa sur le covin de en
avait deux
il aurait anormal on en est pas encore a
déprogrammé mais je crois qu'on commence
à déprogrammer un petit peu où on n'en
finit pas déprogrammé a dit d'accord
mais qu'elle est vous qui connaissez
parfaitement bien la sûreté qu'est ce
que vous proposez en fait parce que vous
proposez jamais rien nous tromper c'est
là vous vous trompez c'est que un jeune
et des ponts dans les lidd réa messieurs
attaqué on a on est à fond les foules
parce qu'on a perdu l'équivalent de la
ville de reims en l'espace de dix ans en
vous avez ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que si le critère c'est à l'iddri ah bah
je vous propose un truc on continue de
baisser le nombre de livrets à on
continue de diminuer et comme ça quand
on arrivera à 100% on doit pas regarder
ya 100% premiers éléments deuxième
élément ce que je propose je vais vous
dire ce que je propose d'avoir une vraie
politique sanitaire d'avoir des gens qui
évitent à gagner sur les plateaux télé
raconter n'importe quoi et qui s'occupe
des patients puisque apparemment il ya
des problèmes de patients en réa parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya trois semaines on
vous disait que si on re confine pas ça
va être la catastrophe
on vous a dit que passer de 20 heures à
18 heures ça allait être effectivement
absolument extraordinaire catherine
catherine il nous a expliqué il ya
quelques jours
bah ça baisse mais ça aurait pas dû
baisser ça en devient donc la preuve
monsieur c'est qu'on ne sait absolument
pas où on va et qu'on décline des mots
auxquels personne ne comprend rien dont
celui de principe de précaution ce que
je sais moi en tant que juriste c'est
qu'il y à une réalité là deux réalités
la première c'est que notre principe de
précaution c'est tout sauf ce qu'on fait
et même le relais mais cela dit le msc
de lui vous dire ouais bon peut-être le
premier confinement on y est allé un peu
fort parce qu'on s'est plantée sur les
chiffres de la chine
donc maintenant il faut peut être
réfléchir au système deuxième élément ce
que je sais c'est que quand le
gouvernement vous en prête une liberté
il oublie toujours de vous la rendre sa
taille elle est bien merci pour moi
c'est cadeau gilles verdez alors là vous
allez voir en termes de voix c'est ce
qu'on fait de mieux
gilles verdez où s'épanouissent et the
voice 1 c'est parti m division la blague
avec tout mon respect c'est vous la
blague
foncez le moule relâchement aujourd'hui
le moindre relâchement et tout repart
c'est comment savez vous défoncer vous
devez être chroniqueur sur tp france et
vont sonner que j'étais militaire pour
venir évoquer des choses sur les clubs
même les scientifiques les plus éminents
s'arrachent les séparent et non
excusez-moi mais on vous avait dit que
si on a un qui n'est pas moi c'est plus
tard même une épidémiologiste comme
catherine gil j'insiste parce que dieu
c'est le respect que j'ai pour elle mais
vous répéter les mêmes choses savais
même pas ce que vous dites vous répéter
trois fois la même chose mais nous les
illuminations ont même expliqué que sans
ces mesures at-elle l'épidémie aurait
repris alors que vous en savez vous
trégor septembre dernier relâché c'est
reparti en super rien et vous non plus
vous et moi je fais un petit peu de
modèles sur le col vides partout où on a
relâché tous les mots tellement réussi
jusqu'ici moi j'ai jamais dit que
j'allais repartir alors contrairement à
4 il
partout on a relâché c'est reparti moi
je dis même que c'est pas une question
de variants c'est une question de
relâchement et je suis d'accord si on
enlève le couvre-feu si on relâche
maintenant ça va repartir et accessible
et je sais ce que les jeunes
n'accepteront pas de se faire on sera
bien obligé la jeune question qui me lie
la question monsieur la chine elle est
relativement simple
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous me dites que
l'espagne est criminel est ce que vous
me dites que l'italie dans laquelle j'ai
vécu sept ans finalement est un pays qui
le 30 mars - monsieur vous explique que
ça va repartir sur la narration mais
qu'est donc monsieur boulava m'explique
les rebelles là est ce qui explique que
les idées font sort effectivement à
gouvernement d' irresponsable qui met sa
population en danger oui ou non mais
vous êtes
cette tendance survivre ici mais je te
rends compte que j'ai regardé ce que
l'épidémie est limité avec moi et sortez
moi ebit est jeune et maîtrisez pas
ouais c'est bien
non mais l'idée c'est à dire excusez moi
monsieur sans avoir recours à l'argument
autorités je pense qu'au maintien santé
publique je pourrais vous en apprendra
certain nombre j'étais en septembre me
demandez pas de temps sept membres mais
aussi répété 100 m mais vous serez
occupé quand vous vous serez occupé de
temps d'épidémie que je m'en suis occupé
eh bien on pourra commencer en discuter
mais revenez pas avec moi parler
effectivement de notre logique auquel
vous n'entendez rien versé comme les
documents reçus blachier à ma question
était relativement simple
est ce que vous dit effectivement que
les italiens sont un gouvernement de
criminels alors deux minutes avant
qu'ils répondent on va lancer la
dernière partie du show alors ça va
l'être comme on est très bien voilà un
petit polo pour moi c'est la wii 2
minutes 1 on a alors s'il ya des
médecins ici qui me dit non je pense pas
que les gouvernements à l'italienne
gouvernement de criminel par contre je
pense que là où ils ont rouvert les
restaurants ils vont pas tarder à devoir
confirmer nous parler d'autre chose
bah oui vous parler d'autre chose si
vous voulez bien effectivement avoir un
peu de précision n'est pas tout mélanger
serait déjà sympa vous êtes vous êtes
tout cas pas si lisse et d'un truc à
l'autre qu'elle parle des coûts du
couvre-feu vous me parlez de retour des
restaurants alors je pouvais aussi
dressé ce match derna mondiale qui dit
non vous allez voir ce qu'il dit lui
c'est le porte parole du gouvernement
plus d'abris première je crois que le
couvre-feu est ce efficace il faut le
maintenir absolument fausse a été
ponctué sa part qui nous le pensons des
places et des chiffres en vue que
c'était une gifle
les sondés show m'a dit que ça a été
prouvé dites-moi par qui fabrice juste
or les chiffres non non non tel chiffre
c'est fini mais on est le problème si
oui quels conseils des médecins
quels conseils des médecins tu le
conseil donne son successeur mais il
avait le fabrice landry non la règle est
ce à dire ça pour des ponts sont déjà
rêver ses comptes et quand ils m'ont dit
ce qui se passe c'est que vous annoncez
des cheveux d'être c'est prouvé il va
parler là le bellâtre perpètrent live et
foncez mais attendez mais quand même des
chiffres qui parlent au co2 et donc
aujourd'hui on est à saturation aux
nîmois 3000 aujourd'hui 3200 main sur
mike déjà dit ce cher la 3d tactile
avait déjà dit si vous me dis que le
couvre-feu et efficace je vous en
demande l'épreuve
fabrice di vizio à quoi vous attribue la
baisse la connaissais déjà encore une
fois monsieur blache il ya trois jours
je vous ai dit je n'ai rien attribué à
rien c'est vrai qu'ils portaient à
tenter des libertés donc c'est à vous de
trouver ça marche ça s'appelle
effectivement monsieur le principe de
précaution exactement ces termes après
ses précautions
je rappelle que la moitié de la
communauté médicale appelée har
confinant jeudi la moitié c'est 95% et
il n'a pas été décidé donc
atalante les seules choses c'est que les
médecins raconte n'importe quoi que le
politique joue son rôle
merci réponse en meilleure démonstration
bon je suis d'accord qui en fait les
affaires des fonctions qu'on ne veut pas
des niches locaux dès lors gilbert
benzema reprend la boutique où après
avoir laissé le parapet oripeaux
ramallah et mettez une tannée et lui ces
messieurs division oui vous cherchez la
singularité et vous fait naufrage
parce qu'en fait une belle phrase ne
veut rien dire en fait à défoncer à 2515
on a lié son couvre-feu ça va exploser
les mines jour où les gens vont sortir
mais nous sommes écoutés ou préfèrent
écouter trois les conneries dans la
connerie j'ai commencé à y penser parce
que là on touche à un secteur tkm
secteur des libertés fondamentales ne
peux pas le blairer sur les rings depuis
tout à l'heure les a et les eaux d'où ma
part les deux proches et litres montant
annoncé aucune
vous me parlez de chypre vous me parlez
de neige se désiste pas abandonné moi
j'accepte de discuter sur les bases
factuelles et une jolie part d'une étude
mois du ch et tous à propos de laquelle
je suis sûr que vous êtes est
extrêmement compétent pour la contredire
qui vous expliquent que le couvre-feu à
toulouse
voilà aggraver la situation tout part
d'une étude qui vous dit que le
couvre-feu n'a aucune incidence
éventuellement peut-être un mélangé à
d'autres mesures
il peut avoir une efficacité si les
mélanger à d'autres mesures vous
explique que probablement peut-être on
ne sait pas si la fermeture des
commerces n'est pas plus à l'origine
voilà deux des dab et sept-îles et nick
la vérité monsieur c'est que vous me
demandiez tout à l'heure ce que je
propose c'est que je propose est déjà
épousé comme jamais vous c'est que vous
arrêtiez de raconter des conneries et il
est résolu on n'est pas là
la résolution c'est que quand vous dites
quelque chose vous puissiez nord prenait
à mesure êtes vous en mesure de mener
que l'atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales a été effectivement
réellement être les fabris
oui ou non la réponse avec binaire mais
toi tu as pas marre télévision vous êtes
capable de porter mais monsieur vous
vous trompez sur un pneu il peut parfois
que des libertés publiques
l'émotion avec monsieur monsieur le
principe c'est à l'heure dé jeu donnant
mon exemple pourquoi tout le monde sur
tombe sur un nouveau bond alors qu'ils
ont les défauts calme ont débarqué on
reproche mais d'affirmer sans prouver
peu importe la véracité mairie n'a pas
le droit mais vous avez le droit mais
j'étais qui nettoie c'est un moins de
prouver fonction des mesures que vous
marchez pas mais vous vivez dans quel
monde
la preuve à l'étamine certains messieurs
j'y peux rien si vous n'avez aucune
notion de liberté fondamentale et un
minimum de connaissance de l'état de
droit et aucune culture en sciences
politiques
j'y parviendrai pas dépenser on va
regarder popularité le couvent
oui à 60 4 26% bah oui parce que les
gens ont envie de liberté c